[Music]
i'm dr kate bieberdorf but you may know
me as kate the chemist kate is a
scientist author and science entertainer
today i'm going to break down clips from
movies and tv about chemistry so let's
experiment dissolving a body breaking
bad
it's possible that hf could dissolve a
body but i would not pick that one
because hf is a weak acid and so that
means that it doesn't fully dissociate
into the hydronium ion and that's the
active species that's actually going to
start eating away at the tissue so if it
was me to dissolve a body even though i
shouldn't be saying this i would
probably go with something closer to
aquaria which is like a royal acid
that last scene makes me cringe he's
standing next to a huge container of hf
so hydrofluoric acid that is being
suspended in the air and he doesn't have
any safety equipment on his face so like
that thing could break and splash in his
face and just he'd be done so no thank
you
when you add acid to something it is
going to start to react immediately we
have a saying in lab that you add acid
to water do what you ought to because if
you add it in the opposite direction it
starts to rip things apart in a really
treacherous way so we usually would take
a body help me out professor no we
wouldn't we would usually take a
substance and then add acid to it we're
ready to go to work
sniffing chemicals it's always sunny in
philadelphia i'm stuck to your glue what
about gasoline pour a little bit of
gasoline on there dissolve some of the
glue in theory in theory maybe gasoline
could actually dissolve glue that's
basic chemistry they have similar
properties and so it's possible that you
could actually use this non-polar
substance gasoline to dissolve something
that's also relatively nonpolar which is
glue so in theory
maybe but there are so many things that
would be better to use and gasoline
would be like the bottom of my list are
you sure it's gasoline though i should
just try it again
jesus please don't huff gasoline at home
it's not a good high though honestly
because the gas can get into your brain
it's one of those things that's very
dense like the molecule is very dense it
also could fill up your lungs and then
you can asphyxiate
chemical brownies rick and morty okay if
we add a little more titanium nitrate
and just a tad of chloride tartrate
ovenless brownies not even close on this
one titanium nitrate is a colorless
solid and chlorified tartrate i think
you said glorified tartrate i am not
familiar with that molecule i'm pretty
sure that does not exist but let's just
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say they were using tartrate which is
essentially the salt of cream of tartar
or tartric acid yeah it's gotta be that
way so we do eat cream of tartar that's
used in a lot of baking recipes so that
piece we could actually eat but if you
took titanium nitrate and mixed it with
cream of tartar you are definitely not
making brownies it's incredible what a
gifted mind can accomplish
sticky substances spiderman homecoming
but trust me there's nothing boring
my big issue is on the right side the
left part that ring i'm okay with that
that's okay but it's when we get to the
right side of it and you see just like a
line attached to it this rogue carbon
and then you have another one attached
to a carbon and another it's just
garbage so like that is just a disaster
of a drawing it's something i would
expect from a high school student and
it's not good
this would not make a sticky substance
at all it would make a clear colorless
solution that kind of looks like salt
water in this experiment we are going to
make nylon which is what i would make if
i was spiderman so i have four different
things in front of me to start with i
have a crystallization dish and so this
is a really round glass dish that is
appropriate to make nylon in
i also have a spatula and that's just
going to be to actually pull my nylon
out so i'm going to start off by pouring
this liquid just to have a little bit at
the bottom so i just want to cover my
crystallization dish completely then i'm
going to take my other reagent my
chloride and i'm going to add that
and right away
we can already see the nylon forming
it's happening it's absolutely working
oh my god i'm so excited
and i've made nylon
look at this
and it just
doesn't stop it just keeps going and i
can keep pulling it in here and i've
made this like awesome polymer look at
this see this is what spiderman should
have done like this is exactly what it
looks like oh my god it's just nonstop
fictional elements vibranium black
panther a meteorite made of vibranium
the strongest substance in the universe
struck the continent of africa
the theory here is actually quite
spot-on i mean that's how elements are
brought to earth there are explosions
that happen in space maybe it's with a
meteorite maybe it's a supernova who
knows what it is but eventually these
pieces these elements actually just like
fling themselves onto earth it's not
just the metal they sew it into their
clothes
it powers their city their tank
unfortunately there is no atom or no
element on the periodic table right now
that resembles vibranium in any way
whatsoever what are you talking about
cooking meth breaking bad
[Music]
in terms of safety i'm pretty good with
this they have the gas mask on then they
have a piece over that that protects
their face so that's going to protect
their eyes and nose as well and they
also are completely covered in some kind
of hazmat suit i really like how they
have their gloves all the way up but
then over the suit so in theory
nothing's going to be dropping down into
them
a lot of the equipment and the processes
used here are very standard so any
standard chemistry lab any industry
place any pharmaceutical place those are
probably going to have all that
equipment all that safety equipment and
in theory you could potentially make
meth there with that glassware and with
the gas mask that you would need
[Music]
that's a very common method we use
stills in our lab when i was in graduate
school to purify our solvents it's a
really old-school way of doing it
[Music]
2.35 pounds to make something that's
like two or three pounds is a lot of
material and you would need to put a lot
of reagents into that is it possible
absolutely for their setup
gasoline fight zoolander
[Music]
i would not douse myself with gasoline
that's typically frowned upon it would
smell terrible but you're also extremely
flammable it's just not a good idea
i do not believe that small the flame
would be able to have that big of an
explosion i don't think the spark from
the lighter would ignite it the actual
flame from the lighter definitely could
light octane vapors on fire or gasoline
vapors on fire but it wouldn't have
those big like explosion points of boom
boom boom that we see in that clip
cigar explosion national lampoon's
christmas vacation sewer gas
don't drop that
even though the chemistry is not perfect
here i do like it sewer gas typically
contains a mixture of hydrogen sulfide
some ammonia some carbon dioxide maybe
maybe some methane the hydrogen sulfide
is really what i'd be worried about
there that is toxic and it is
extraordinarily flammable yeah
and thanks for telling us and anytime
you have gases that are trapped in like
an area that's when you can essentially
make a bomb and so if it's trapped in a
small pipe or a small area it's gonna
explode it's gonna push out so you
definitely will see an explosion but not
nearly like that
cigarette explosion con air
nara
this is a big myth cigarettes rarely
cause an explosion like this you would
need that cigarette to land perfectly
like have that light that actual fire
directly connect with any of that liquid
that's flammable but unless it lands
perfectly like this is just not gonna
happen looks like you missed your
connection chloroform community excuse
me who are you guys this is not your
office
so when you take chloroform and you put
it on a rag and you try to smother
someone it actually takes quite a long
time i've never done it personally but
from what i've read it sounds like it
takes about five minutes so you don't
just immediately pass out
what's happening
oh
we all got chloroformed with a small
amount of it you essentially get that
euphoric feeling that temporary euphoric
feeling like you do with any other drug
or alcohol but then you pass out
like with alcohol
would you stop
testing for purity blow what i'm doing
here is measuring the purity
pure coke uh it melts away at about a
185 190 degrees so by definition when we
use the word pure in the chemistry world
that means we have a hundred percent of
just those molecules so pure cocaine
would be a vial of pure cocaine there's
no meth in there there's no corn starch
in there it is just cocaine 187
where did you get this stuff so he's
using a very interesting version of a
melting point apparatus we use this a
lot anytime you're actually trying to
characterize a molecule so the first
time a molecule is made and you're
trying to publish that you want to know
the melting point and so this is a
really easy way for you to quickly test
your material and see if it's good
chemical burn fight club this is a
chemical
i don't like it he's intentionally
throwing sodium hydroxide which is lie a
base a very strong base onto your hand
you've heard more than you've ever been
burned and you will have a squad
the movie's wrong here because it
doesn't burn like that that's not really
what a chemical burn with a base feels
like that's more what it would feel like
with an acid when you put a base on your
hand like that your hand actually feels
really slippery because it sucks the
fats out i know it's gross of your hand
but it sucks the fats out of your hand
and you start to feel like really
slippery and you're kind of making soap
like literally on your hand this is the
best soup
creating foam big bang theory we're
going to combine these chemicals with
ordinary dish soap creating a little
exothermic release of oxygen
this science is good yeah i'm all about
this one for elephant's toothpaste which
is the reaction he's making what you do
is you take concentrated hydrogen
peroxide so that's why he's wearing
gloves usually about 35 hydrogen
peroxide you add it to a mixture of dish
soap so some really bubbly dish soap and
i usually add food coloring to make it
colorful and then you add your catalyst
your potassium iodide and that's what
decomposes hydrogen peroxide to release
oxygen gas so yeah sheldon was right
sheldon you remind me of a young lex
luthor he uses the phrase exothermic
release of oxygen exothermic release of
oxygen that means you're releasing
oxygen and also releasing heat energy so
you probably can see at the very top or
right on the outside of the reaction you
can actually see those heat waves and
it's just heat energy being pushed off
as the decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide occurs so let's do exactly what
sheldon just did we're going to make
elephant's toothpaste so in order to do
this you need an erlenmeyer flask so
something that's wide at the bottom and
then narrow at the top you're also going
to need hydrogen peroxide and you want
concentrated hydrogen peroxide you'll
also need some dish soap i highly
recommend non-natural dish soap and then
i have my potassium iodide which is a
catalyst and that's going to actually
activate this reaction let's get started
so the first thing i'm going to do is
add my hydrogen peroxide to my
erlenmeyer flask so we'll just add this
whole thing in here want a nice big
reaction then what i'm going to do is
add my dish soap in here and so the dish
soap is actually going to trap the
oxygen gas that's released once i add my
catalyst got to give it a little swoosh
then we're going to add our food
coloring so this is the yellow
you could add any color you want but i
want it to match sheldon i'm going to
give it a little shake
to prep my catalyst this is the best
part and then on the count of three i'm
just gonna add this directly into my
flask
one
two and three
let's see what we get here
this is amazing so you have hydrogen
peroxide it decomposed it released
oxygen gas which was trapped in the dish
soap we also see liquid water is
actually um condensing on the outside of
the container and then hopefully you can
see all of the steam these heat works
because this is an exothermic release of
oxygen gas just like sheldon said
gene altering chemicals spiderman
[Music]
stay away from green gas you never want
to breathe in green gas what i love
about this is that he essentially is
doing a really fun chemical reaction
inside of his body so the first thing he
does is he drinks something which is
essentially a primer some kind of
molecule that will react with the gas so
he needs to have that in his body
because we don't actually have that the
green gas comes in and then like
supposedly magically he has a chemical
reaction between the two and it's just
garbage i'm something of a scientist
myself
explaining a nuclear reactor chernobyl
there are essentially two things that
happen inside a nuclear reactor
the reactivity which generates power
either goes up
or it goes down his explanation of a
nuclear reactor is beautiful i love the
way he describes it fuel increases
reactivity
control rods and water reduce it
essentially what you do is you take a
fuel source and you release energy from
that source of fuel and then you funnel
that energy through the power plant he
does a great job of this because he
really expresses how the nuclear fuel is
dangerous but it can be kept under
control if you have all the other
parameters locked into place it is
beautiful
explaining a nuclear disaster chernobyl
when the core is running at full power
it burns the xenon away before it can
cause a problem but chernobyl reactor 4
has been held at half power for 10 hours
i love how he talks about xenon and how
cute is he at how he says it zenon
xenon's an inert gas and so it really
limits reactivity it's not something
that's very explosive it doesn't really
want to react with things but at high
enough temperatures we can burn it off
and so when
we have too much xenon present but it's
not at high enough temperatures we
essentially start poisoning the reactor
at long last we have arrived
123.45
explosion
what happened is they dunked these
graphite rods directly into the water
and it essentially had enough energy to
boil the water up first of all so the
water is going to go from the liquid
state to the gas phase but it also had
enough energy to split water into
hydrogen and oxygen and when hydrogen is
around oxygen with enough pressure and
with enough energy it was so hot it
immediately becomes combustible so we
build up the pressure we set hydrogen on
fire we blow the roof off and then
that's gonna grab every single
radioactive material in those nuclear
rods and they're just gonna shoot them
everywhere and it was a huge problem
they believe the radiation was airborne
for about nine days just terrifying
safety first
always
chemistry equipment mr bean the whole
bean
don't do that
i hate that he's not wearing goggles
he's not wearing gloves he doesn't have
a lab coat on he put two liquids to his
face that he doesn't know what they are
and then mix them together that's just
like a big no
this setup is a disaster it would never
happen in real life what drives me the
most crazy is that all the tubes are
basically wired backwards you always
shoot liquid cold liquid into the bottom
pump up to the top and then you filter
it out the top every single one in this
clip is set up backwards until the water
is flowing in the wrong direction
liquid nitrogen terminator 2 judgment
day hasta la vista baby
it's possible that you could cover
something in liquid nitrogen and then
shoot it and have a an explosion like
that it's possible is it going to happen
exactly like that unlikely liquid
nitrogen is one of my favorite things on
planet earth so in the terminator 2 clip
we saw that there was this liquidy thing
that was frozen with liquid nitrogen and
then it was shattered with a bullet and
so we're going to try to replicate that
so the first thing i'm gonna do is put
my safety goggles on and then i'm going
to put my cryogenic gloves on liquid
nitrogen is cryogenic it's very very
cold i've got hot dogs hot dogs are
gonna kind of replicate what happens if
like human flesh went in there now this
is disgusting i'm just gonna put that
out there i have to stick my hand in
there and get it oh let me try to grab
it it is like rock hard
oh my gosh so that's like we're gonna
pretend human flesh that we froze with
liquid nitrogen one two three
so let's use this experiment to conclude
that if you dunked a human or a robot in
liquid nitrogen and then tried to hit it
with a bullet or a hammer you absolutely
would be able to destroy the villain
case closed
ingesting toxic chemicals radium girls
watch me
don't do it
this actually used to happen a hundred
percent they would dip the paint brush
in there and then put it into their
mouth to get into this nice like
pinpoint tip and then they would be able
to very precisely paint these different
dials on the top of clocks and
essentially what they're doing is using
a paint that contains radium to give
that nice like glow-in-the-dark effect
everyone put down your brushes radium is
in the same group as calcium in the
periodic table so it means it's in the
same column radium actually is going to
get into these little gaps where calcium
usually sits in your jaw and so it kind
of sinks into these holes and then it
starts just like pulsing out radiation
so right away when you're licking the
paint it's just going to taste bad but
you're not going to notice the fact that
you're absolutely killing yourself while
doing this but like a year or two later
when you've had enough radium deposit in
these bones then it starts shooting out
these alpha beta and gamma rays and that
is what's actually causing cancer and
the dentists were the first people to
figure it out because they were seeing
all these girls come in with these huge
issues in their jaw and the only thing
they had in common is that they all
worked at the same spot invisible inc
national treasure
[Music]
there are two common ways of using lemon
juice for secret messages one of them is
if you have baking soda and you kind of
paint the baking soda onto your surface
your canvas whatever and then you can
actually use lemon juice and kind of
coat it over there and then it will
bubble and kind of elevate the secret
message will the second way would be to
actually use lemon juice to write the
message to actually code the message and
then you can expose it to heat and the
message will appear but neither of those
things happened here so this is pretty
much just bad science
sorry
toxic chemicals casino royale
a hundred percent you could poison
someone this way sodium cyanide is very
very water soluble so it looks like they
dissolved the salt in water and then
dumped it into the martini glass so
depending on how much cyanide was there
you absolutely could kill the person if
there's enough yeah this would work
it's very possible that he would start
feeling nauseous getting dizzy the
sweating the really quick and so all
three of those factors together would
probably
clue someone like james bond into
knowing that he's been poisoned there is
one antidote that we know of and it
works extraordinarily well
so the first thing you need to do is you
need to inhale an enamel nitrate that's
followed by an iv that's filled of
sodium nitrate which is then followed by
a second iv that has sodium thiosulfate
that last hand
nearly killed me
handling dangerous chemicals the rock
really elegant string of pearls
configuration the vx nerve agent is
absolutely real it is a neurotoxin which
means it goes into your body and affects
either your central or peripheral
nervous system you know how this [ __ ]
works this one specifically makes it so
that your muscles can't relax so your
muscles can still contract like your
heart can still beat but then it can't
relax oh my god the only reason you
would use vx nerve gas is to hurt
somebody or kill someone there's no
functional or practical reason to use it
to injure the small of your back as the
poison
seizes your nervous system do not move
that one of the biggest thing that
drives me nuts about this is that we're
seeing the vx in the gas phase and it
only exists in the gas phase at really
really high temperatures and so these
little green bubbles or those little
balls are filled with green gas which
must be at high temps yet somehow
they're like just carrying it around
without being around something like none
of the science really matches for that
so it should really be in the liquid
phase right now which is an amber color
all right just back away
making water the martian i have
hundreds of liters of unused hydrazine
at the ndv
if i run the hydrazine over an iridium
catalyst
it'll separate into n2 and h2 well he's
starting off with hydrazine so n2h4 and
so that's something that's used as
essentially rocket fuel and so he has a
lot of that leftover and what he's going
to do is then take an iridium catalyst
which again found on his equipment
combine the two and that breaks apart
the hydrazine into nitrogen and hydrogen
it also makes ammonia which he didn't
mention but i understand why he left
that part off so this chemistry is
really clean here
hydrazine is extremely flammable
it would be able to propel a rocket
through space which is extremely
important but in the context of this
movie there's a big piece that we've
overlooked because i'm stupid it's very
very toxic and so if he's using
hydrazine at all he needs to be in some
kind of hazmat suit his space suit at
the very least so yeah
i blew myself up i do not think he would
have survived that explosion not at all
he would have had at least second-degree
burns but more likely third-degree burns
and those are painful let's not talk
about that ever again conclusion so
overall movies typically portray
chemistry in a explosive light you see
over and over again that a small spark
causes a huge explosion or a little huff
of a molecule all of a sudden makes you
pass out and die what i love about that
though is that people love including
chemistry in their movies and in their
tv shows and so i will always be happy
about that